c'est une affaire qui depuis plusieurs
jours est au coeur de toutes les
polémiques sur internet la vidéo d'un
jeune homme qui agressent dans la rue le
polémiste eric zemmour et qui a décidé
le post est lui même la vidéo sur son
compte ce match at on le sait eric
zemmour est un journaliste qui divise
il est devenu une cible d'une partie de
la population qui n'hésite plus à le
prendre à partie dans la rue quitte à
dépasser les limites
exemple avec cette séquence où le
journaliste marche d'un pas rapide pour
échapper à cet individu qui l'insultait
le menace une séquence tout de suite
condamnée par de nombreuses
personnalités comme son compère de
toujours eric naulleau suite à la
diffusion de cette séquence sur les
réseaux sociaux le parquet de paris a
annoncé l'ouverture d'une enquête pour
violences et menaces et vous soutenez
vous eric zemmour alors soutenez vous
eric zemmour on a vu cette séquence on
va revoir cette séquence qui a été filmé
il ya jean messia qui nous a rejoint
membres du bureau du rassemblement
national il y a christine kelly
il y a guillaume mélanie coprésidents
d'urgence homophobie merci d'être là et
il y à eric naulleau bien entendu qui
est une proche de thiais notre ami déjà
eric naulleau et bien sûr qui travaille
avec eric zemmour tout comme christine
kelly d'amour qui est magnifique
d'ailleurs elle est toujours belle celle
ci confinement pas confinement elle est
toujours exceptionnel toujours très bien
alors est-ce qu'on peut revoir cette
vidéo qui a énormément tourné s'il vous
plaît laissez le dossier du jour
soutenez-vous eric zemmour on vous pose
la question c'est vrai que cette vidéo a
tourné partout
c'est ce qu'a fait le plus réagir ce
week-end regardez on revoit la vidéo en
entier merci à huy
christine je te vois regarder revoir ces
images
ils n'ont pas eu d'ailleurs ils ont
coupé un peu avant il aurait dû la
mettre en entier ce qu'est ce qu'on a la
vidéo en entière du chat s'il te plaît
ma chérie ce qu'on peut avoir la vidéo
en entier parce que 7 6 6 voilà on va on
va en 20 ans va lancer le 12 mai et
christine je te sens religieux
extrêmement ému quand tu vois ça je t'ai
vu limite les larmes aux yeux
non mais c'est vrai hcc c'est vrai vous
m'avez observé parce que lorsque j'ai vu
cette vidéo dès jeudi soir j'ai été
touché parce que on sent que qui en
fuite qui n poursuite qui a des mots
très violents qui a des mots très durs
et on se dit est ce qu est ce qui mérite
ça au nom de quoi on peut aller on peut
aller là alors bien sûr il n'y a pas eu
d'atteinte à l'intégrité physique sur ce
il ya eu un crash a bien sûr comme il
l'a dit lui même
mais je trouve que on voit eric zemmour
partie à la tête baissée on se dit ça
pourrait peut être moi ça aurait pu être
une autre fille ça pour être quelqu'un
d'autre
donc sur ces mots ont cette vidéo elle
est violente et al khaimah alors donc
quelques minutes après donc le poursuit
et quelques minutes après ils se filment
le jeune homme voilà qui a fait ça doit
y voit son visage on voit son compte
regardez et regardez ce qui s'est créé
un précédent et vous a fait plaisir en
tout cas ça a coupé il y avait des
gouttes de pluie qui tombait sur mon
téléphone j'ai pas pu fournir la vidéo
jusqu'au bout je peux vous dire il a
goûté un mollard allen spéciaux alors
derrière sur les réseaux sociaux
ça a été un déferlement on a pu voir
plus de cent cinquante mille tweets dont
une grande vague de soutien pour
dénoncer l'agression du polémiste
marlène schiappa a dit les injures
publiques et les menaces d'agressions
sexuelles sont injustifiables qu'elle
vise une femme ou un homme eric zemmour
nos amis dans la rue ou sur twitter
ce n'est pas une question de personnes
c'est une question de principe un
principe n'est pas variable
eric ciotti à tout le monde la licra
même la litra voilà eric zemmour est un
adversaire nous combattons ses idées
mais nous voulons exprimer aujourd'hui
notre soutien total face à la chasse à
l'homme et aux crachats dont il a été
victime jamais la violence doit
l'emporter ou être justifiée jamais eric
naulleau vous qui êtes vraiment vous
êtes proche d'eric zemmour quand vous
avez vu ces images est ce que vous dites
il faut soutenir eric zemmour ou pas
parce qu'il ya plein de gens moi je vous
dis sur les réseaux sociaux là qui me
disent voilà moi je vous dis je ne le
soutiens pas ni dans un même si voilà je
ne cautionne pas ce qu'a fait les
garçons mais je ne soutiens pas eric
zemmour
mine de rien il ya aussi des gens qui
nous disent ils nous crachent dessus à
l'antenne ou en télé tout le temps
c'était une occasion peut-être pour le
jeune homme de se défendre et de lui
répondre
voilà après je vois tout je vous dis
tout ce que je lis à voilà je trouve pas
de ce genre d'agression aussi verbale
cela ne sert à rien si on n'est pas
d'accord
eric naulleau moi je soutiens non
seulement eric bellon des jeux soutient
ainsi très simple c'est que nul ne
devrait être victimes d'agressions
verbales ou physiques au motif qu'on ne
partage pas ses opinions ce n'est pas
une manière d'exprimer nos clients
ensuite je n'appellerai pas le jeune
homme je l'appellerai la racaille moi je
serai toujours
alors moi je n'aime pas ce mot j'aime
pas ce mot eric je te dis la vérité
non mais moi j'aime j'aime pas ce mot je
te le dis ben brahim a dit le vainqueur
ça veut dire ça veut dire quoi une
racaille eric ça veut dire quoi ira
glass inconscient ce monde ouvert
guillot voilà donc temps pour moi je
dirais qu'elles passeront oui j'ai pris
sur moi je trouve que je trouve qu'on
porte le nom simplement je veux pas
parler à la place d'eric zemmour ils
apprennent et même si c'est son choix je
peux redire juste que en ce qui le
concerne pour ce qui me concerne
nous avons déjà été victimes
d'agressions plus violente que celle ci
et qui n'ont pas été filmée donc a pas
de traces film est né un jour ou l'autre
il y aura l'agression de trop ce ne
seront pas des paroles
ce ne seront pas des crachats ce sera
quelque chose de beaucoup plus grave
et peut-être que ce jour-là on
regrettera de ne pas nommer les gens
pour ce qu'ils sont à savoir des voyous
je regrette ce n'est pas tout son
appartement admissibles vous ne pouvez
pas être demain ce sera vous ceux qui
ricanent ou frais moins les malins quand
ce sera vous qui aurait découlé
queyranne kirikkanat eric qu'erica
eric ericsson est ok ricane mais qu eric
ané eric vous parlez de qui là moi je
parle de sur les réseaux sociaux soit
ceux qui ricanent aux dépens de zemmour
soit ce ça c'est encore une autre
catégorie intéressant qui préfère ne
rien dire parce que dans ces cas-là
courage fuyons il ne faut pas prendre
parti je regrette mais mes différents
mais désaccords idéologiques avec les
mots n'ont pas diminué d'un centimètre
après cette agression
j'ai toujours des différends avec ces
mots je vous dis juste que d'avoir des
différents avec des mots ce n'est pas
une manière de les régler ou lui
crachant dessus en insultant sa personne
et celle de sa mère
j'aurais si vous admettez ça c'est la
fin de la démocratie eric naulleau ce
que vous l'avez au téléphone eric
zemmour bien sûr je vais en avril vous
aviez loi bah il me raconte surtout nous
dévoiler mais il vous a dit quoi ils
étaient ils et elles étaient touchés il
était comment il a été touché mais comme
je voulais dit c'est pas le genre de
zéro au mois moi-même d'année nous
plaindre sur les sur les réseaux sociaux
quand ça arrive mais ce n'est pas la
première fois et ce sera probablement
pas la dernière
donc il prend tout comme moi il prend
ses comportements inadmissibles comme
une forme de routine
c'est la routine de l'agression verbale
sur les réseaux sociaux et c'est la
routine d'une certaine agression
physique qui peut aller bien plus loin
que ce qu'on voit sur ces sur ces vidéos
dans dans la vraie vie je crois que
franchement il doit y avoir une prise de
conscience je pense que beaucoup de gens
ne comprennent pas que c'est ça
l'ordinaire de certaines personnes qui
cristallise contre eux une forme de
haine qui peuvent aller très très loin
et je vous en parle en connaissance de
cause j'étais confronté à des situations
extrêmement difficile extrêmement dure
un jour ou l'autre viendra ce sera
peut-être passé alors j'aimerais qu'on
entend des gens mais si guillaume
mélanie alors guillaume mélanie vous
êtes le coprésident d'urgence homophobie
vous vous dites quoi parce que je sais
que vous êtes extrêmement remonté contre
eric zemmour tout au long de l'année
donc là vous dit quoi sur cette
agression
oui le reste de l'année chez évidemment
jeu absolument quasiment aucun propos de
du personnage ou de l'homme oh il joue
un rôle ou si vraiment ce qu'ils pensent
donc oui les halles les agressions
verbales les insultes et l'intimidation
dans la rue après pardonnez moi mais
quand eric naulleau nous dit déjà le
traite
je maintiens
conclut que vous mainteniez voilà vous
l'appelez comment vous d'un canal voilà
voyous et caïds délinquants je suis pro
j c on a bien compris ceux d'été dans le
jugement et dans la viande guillaume
n'est pas là on est pas la banque
s'embrouiller avec eric et qu'eric
naulleau juste dites nous ce que vous en
avez pensé maintenant parce que quand
quand eric naulleau se désole cyril non
mais j'ai dites nous ce que vous en avez
pensé et rés
guillot moi je vais pas parler à
l'indignation nationale je regrette
cette agression verbale
ça n'a pas lieu d'être
après il faut aussi comprendre et savoir
que ces personnes que ce soit les
personnes musulmanes les femmes
le rx d moore smatis gouttes vous les
personnes lgbt dont se répartiront se
fait insulter toute l'année à l'antenne
encore la dernière fois je vais parler
jour descend aux enfers
pardon et je vous laisseront eric si
vous plaidez c'est finir oui mais je
l'étais moi si vous êtes un couple eric
naulleau si vous trouviez le
cessionnaire c'est très bien on n'a pas
besoin de de vote mais je ne sais pas
d'où jaillit mais l'émission pardonnez
moi allez on y va aller à l'aiguillon à
l'ellipse internationale on n'est pas
obligé de se prononcer sur chacune des
agressions la scène conventionnelle
n'est pas acceptable mais elle n'est pas
acceptable
bien que ce soit eric zemmour même si
c'est exact mais il faut comprendre
aussi que mon et insulté en permanence
par cette personne et que ce ce mec ce
monsieur cet homme ce jeune homme et non
pas du tout cette racaille a perdu son
sang froid face à un mec il insulte ou
qui insultent des portes ils se sont
représentés une année stable de droite
je vous ai pas recoupé avec nenê ricard
était assez pénible vraiment c'est
pénible
on a laissé la mi octobre elle est
indiscutablement pas acceptable mais
c'est aussi une seule pile poil mot pour
mot la semaine que ville des femmes tous
les jours dans la rue mais mon cautionne
pas ça à personne de cosenza elle
guillaume on nous pose on n'a pas dit on
après passé on n'a pas dit que c'était
bien on a pas dit que c'était bien car
ça à mesure que je ne cautionne pas ça
vraiment et ça m'embête plus qu'autre
chose pour espérer eu lieu corps parce
qu'elle prend une part médiatique trop
importante dans une période où les
violences conjugales éclater ou les
violences pour les électeurs à faire le
tri des violences l'apparence est
injustifiable et inacceptable
soyons bien d'accord une fois ce
principe posé je vais dire que juste je
vois là ce jeune alors ce n'est pas lié
au plaisir à voir mais je ne vais pas
participer comme marlène schiappa ou
comme eric naulleau nous demande à tous
les responsables associatifs de réagir
sur cette accusation
j'ai d'autres priorités il ya une femme
encore hier soir à torcy bien sûr ma rue
ou par son père non comprises les
comprendre il faut arrêter de nous
demander de faire le violon toute
l'année il ya plein de personnes
innocentes qui n'ont jamais agressé et
insulté personne qui se font insulter
bon ben là c'est le revers de la
médaille lors de la manche suivante on
va voir ce qu'on va voir beaucoup de
vins servis aux pgm avec vous de dijon
merci à mener ce que j'aimerais qu'on
doit la vidéo super j'aimerais qu'on
voit la vidéo pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent et qu'on ait la vie de gens
mais si après vous allez voir que le
garçon s'est excusé ensuite vous allez
voir ce qu'il a dit mais juste regardons
la première vidéo celle qui a fait
énormément parler je voudrais avoir
l'avis de jean bessière après c'est
parti
pierrick way sécrestat précédent et vous
a fait plaisir en tout cas ça a coupé il
y avait des gouttes de pluie qui tombait
sur mon téléphone j'ai pas pu pour la
vidéo jusqu'au bout je peux vous dire
qu'il a goûté un mollard allen spiesser
alors jean messia bien entendu vous avez
réagi sur les réseaux sociaux vous
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous dites
de ça vous êtes forcément choqué vous
pensez qu'il faut soutenir eric zemmour
évidemment un last n a choqué la france
entière d'ailleurs heureusement qu'elle
est réseaux sociaux pour avoir égalé
cette scène parce que sinon évidemment
les médias officiels mensuels javari
lui-même c'est le jeune homme lui-même
qui l'a révélé ben justement mais c'est
ça c'est ça qui est scandaleux vous
rendez compte que quel en france vous
avez quelqu'un qui insulte qui fait
preuve d'une violence inouïe à l'égard
de quelqu'un simplement parce qu'ils en
désaccord avec lui et il se filme lui il
a le culot de ce film est lui même
quelque part cette personne-là se sent
protégé par des élites qui vont de toute
façon quoi qu'il fasse le considérer
comme une victime
dès lors qu'il est issu d'une certaine
immigration c'est ça la vérité les gens
qui sont des spécialistes des heures
sombres qui n'ont par la longueur de
journée des heures les plus sombres de
l'histoire à moi quand je vois une scène
pareille je vois un juif dans les années
30 est poursuivi par des nazillons voyez
c'est ça ce que je vois et quand
j'entends monsieur mélanie nous dire que
c'est une agression qui normal parce que
eric zemmour je n'ai jamais dit que
c'était il ya dix ans qu'ils ont fait
guillaume coupez coupez coupez les
vergers temps pendant un temps mais sia
les enfants de des excuses et à demi mot
cette agression en la vidant de sa
substance
je vous rappelle quand même que les
actes d'homophobie et d'antisémitisme en
viennent majoritairement d'une certaine
immigration ouvre à reese est arrêté
mais les dardenne mais il faut que je
quitte bel nos gènes l'immigration de
jeudi bien de certaines immigrations
parce que la question est là et enfin
jeudi un dernier mot là c'est arrivé à
aiguiser à eric zemmour
on en parle mais il faut vous dire que
ce type de comportement vous avez des
milliers des dizaines de milliers de
français qui chaque jour et suis ce type
de comportement dans un anonymat absolu
parce que ce sont pas des gens connus la
violence le vivre ensemble c'est un
vivre avec vivre avec l'antisémitisme
vivre avec la délinquance vivre avec le
terrorisme vivre avec l'homophobie
il faut pas vous aveugle et il faut
juste juste dire les choses telles
qu'elles sont alors alors il ya
guillaume mélanie nous disait tout à
l'heure ils nous disaient ils
cautionnent pas bien sur ce qui s'est
passé mais il disait c'est peut-être une
réponse aussi à tout ce qu'a dit eric
zemmour on va revenir sur quelques
voiles à paris entre le 6 mars 2010 eric
et moi et fait beaucoup parler lui sur
le plateau de salut les terriens
c'est en expliquant en toute détente que
pour lui tous les trafiquants étaient
principalement des noirs et des arabes
ça voilà ça c'était inadmissible
regarder ce qu'il avait dit à l'époque
dans salut les terriens figc dans ces
quartiers je mélange pas tout dit on
attendait que je ne mets la pratique de
la polygamie aux sims a tenté il ya
beaucoup de telara du tout tu n'es pas
l'apanage des quartiers populaires de
nos politiques
on a quand même un maire de levallois
dans les milieux que vous fréquentez
égard le trafic de drogue délinquance en
col voyez une petite différé rick tu
prends l'histoire à un moment donné
comme s'il n'y avait pas une séquence
avant alors tu dis les gens abandonner
veulent vivre comme ça non dès l'instant
qu'on est contrôlé 17 fois dans la
journée
ça modifie le caractère si ça t'arrive
et moi on est contrôlé en journée parce
que la plupart des trafiquants sont
noirs et arabes c'est comme ça c'est un
fait
alors ils sont trompés d'extraits ça
c'était son petit et son clash avec
rokhaya diallo que j'embrasse d'ailleurs
regardez cette phrase voilà qu'il a dit
qui peut et qui a pu énerver c'est un
deuil une accumulation de phrase voilà
et je vais avoir l'avis de christine
kelly juste après vous alors aulas pas
mais c'est vrai qu'il avait dit ça on
avait 4 ans et réinsérer qu'il a dit
plein de choses aussi chez vous
christine kelly vous l'avez vu
aujourd'hui eric zemmour était dans quel
état alors on l'a vu est il justement il
s'est exprimé à propos de cette
agression sur le plateau tout à l'heure
en direct alors comment ils n'avaient
pas n'avaient pas trop envie d'en parler
il disait que ça lui arrive tout le
temps ça lui arrive très souvent et en
général ils cachent ces agressions il
était dans quel état dans un état où
pour lui ça a pris beaucoup de
proportions qui ne voulait pas que ça
prenne autant propension troisième mois
il a souligné que tout le monde a
souligné ce soir c'est à dire que ça
arrive à toutes sortes de femmes
enceintes ni à toutes sortes de
personnes et qui veut se noyer dans la
masse alors je lui fais remarquer que
souhaite pas forcément pour les idées et
que lui c'est pour ses idées et
justement lui c'est une sorte de
confusion entre les idées et les
identités et c'est là où il ya une sorte
de mélange des violences
on a beaucoup parlé à présent de la
violence des gilet jaune qui se disait
que ils vont tout brûler parce qu'ils
subissent une violence sociale et c'est
ce que ressent ce jeune homme c'est à
dire qu'il ressent une certaine violence
de la part des propos à dabo d'eric
zemmour parce que sur le plateau il est
plutôt plutôt maîtrisée en ce moment et
rose sont simples une certaine violence
et lui c'est sa façon d'agir ce n'est
pas du tout pour l'excuser parce que
personne ne l'excusé d'ailleurs il a
fait 55 secondes d'excusés n'ai cessé ce
alors là qui on va regarder ligue avait
commencé sa violence et on va on va
regarder regarder l'auteur des faits qui
s'appelle arabe la gratuité sur les
réseaux a publié
dimanche les explications sur snapshot
alors pour expliquer son geste il
explique
voilà qui est voilà tout simplement
qu'en le croisant dans la rue s'est
laissé emporter sans pouvoir se
maîtriser mais il explique toutefois
qu'il n'y aurait pas cracher dessus en
fait qu'il avait voilà rajouter ça pour
faire certainement le beau devant les
copains regarde bonsoir je tiens à faire
cette intervention pourrait m'expliquer
sur ce qui s'est passé
tout d'abord jour là je n'entendais pas
à croiser une rixe des mots une personne
avec lequel champ total des accords sur
ses idées et surtout ce qui est véhiculé
en voyant je me suis laissé emporter 2
ne lui est pas cracher dessus
on peut voir dans une vidéo que j'ai
publié par la suite me vanter lui avoir
craché dessus
mais c'est complètement faux et dans sa
vidéo il dit aussi il explique aussi
qu'il s'excuse s'excuse pour son geste
qu'il regrette énormément regarder chez
que j'ai mal agi j'aurais pas dû agir de
cette façon j'ai pu le blesser et choqué
beaucoup de monde et je regrette
vraiment mon geste est par contre je
n'ai agi au nom d'aucune communauté et
contre aucune communauté
alors vous l'avez dire c'est pas la
première fois qu'eric zemmour est pris à
partie dans la rue le journaliste et
gilet jaune isadora duncan l'avait suivi
dans les rues de paris l'année dernière
et ce soir là eric zemmour avait dénoncé
ce qui était pour lui du harcèlement et
vous allez me dire si vous acceptez les
excuses de ce jeune homme juste après
qu'il a fait sur ce cap chat ou si vous
pensez que c'est parce que je crois
qu'il ya une enquête qui va être ouvert
donc peut-être que voilà il s'est dit
qu'il fallait peut-être qu'ils mettent
voilà qui met un petit peu d'eau dans
son vin qu'il va des excuses regarder
d'abord ce qu'ils avaient dit récuser
mort monsieur zemmour
alors est-ce que vous pensez que la
soirée je réponds quand christine mais
pourquoi je vous répondrai pas aux
questions mais exactement extrêmes
maintien monsieur
je ne vous mais je ne suis pas une vache
et on triait pas mon lait alors qu'est
votre intelligence et votre lait je
pense qu aux cheveux et je n'ai pas vous
répondre
monsieur zemmour écoutez maintenant je
vous dénoncez mais pour pouvoir était de
me harceler mais c'est du harcèlement
l'amant merdé
monsieur zemmour 2,3 thérèse regardez là
vous m'emmerdez est ok mais pourquoi
vous mettez vous pouvez vous mettre dans
tous vos états je ne leur ai pas dans
tous mes états vous m'emmerdez mais vous
n'avez l'hôte et là vous l'avez
enregistré
oui vous m'emmerdez ok alors avec des
mots donc vous l'avez dit voilà ça
c'était une autre voie là il avait été
suivi donc par un journaliste eric vous
dit que ça lui arrive très souvent c'est
ce que vous avez dit christine kelly
est-ce que vous pardonner ce que vous
excuser ce jeune homme après cette vidéo
qu'il a fait sur snapshot
on va entendre guillaume mélanie dans un
instant je vais avoir l'avis de jean
messia et d'eric naulleau d'abord genre
mais siaba et c'est écoutez moi les
excuses des excuses de circonstance
parce que probablement dictée par un
avocat par son avocat qui va le défendre
j'aimerais juste dire à monsieur mélanie
mais regardez si ça avait été un roc aya
diallo qui à longueur de journée insulte
les blancs accuse les blancs des tenants
d'un famille etc
vous savez et de calais diallo avait été
attaqué par un blanc ou pas un
extrémiste
alex est veste blanc voudrait dit quoi
vous l'auriez traité de criminel de
délinquants de racaille a juste dit
alors je suis pas d'accord avec vous sur
rokhaya diallo okaya diallo en exprime
ses idées et c'est le contenu est là
elle fait jamais de racisme anti-blancs
rokhaya là mais la logique garmin
l'heure mais le niveau être d'une
minorité n'est pas ne confère pas un
droit à l'insulté avec une certaine
immunité derrière on est un délinquant
quand on est noir quand on est blanc
quand on est à à quelle que soit la
religion ou l'ethnie dont vous êtes si
vous êtes un délinquant ou un criminel
il faut appeler les choses par leur nom
et il faut arrêter ce relativisme qui
pour le coup relève du racisme chance
nous et jean messier accepte pas quand
les animaux excuse moi je les accepte
pas parce que c'est exactement que ces
imams qui prêchent qui produisent des
vidéos sur les réseaux sociaux et quand
on leur dit mais attendez votre vidéo là
vous êtes homophobe vous faites de
l'homophobie où vous êtes vous fait de
l'antisémitisme ont dit ah oui mais vous
savez j'ai dit ça comme ça au hasard
en réalité c'est une religion de paix
d'amour jeu ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'islam
c'est exactement la même chose là je
pense que dans vont assumer les actes
qui ont prêté de l'argent mais charrie
et de délinquance il faut appeler les
choses par leur nom et arrêter de se
payer de bons sentiments parce que nous
sommes en france et en france ce n'est
pas à la france de s'exprimer eric
zemmour en l'occurrence il a une liberté
de parole
si on n'est pas d'accord avec lui on va
discuter avec lui c'est ça la france se
comporter autrement c'est ne pas être
français est malheureusement il y a
beaucoup de noms français en france
désormais jean jean messieurs juste une
petite question tout ce confinement tout
ça ça vous a pas détendu un mois vous
voulez ça me met en colère ça mais c'est
ce comportement
cette violence de mets en colère quelle
que soit la victime
gênée on est dans un petit paquet c'est
vraiment parlé quelles seraient les
images qu'elle peut mais j'en ai bien
sûr en toute violence est condamné et
condamnable moi je ne suis pas de ceux
qui font du relativisme
je n'excuse pas en fonction de la race
la religion défense voilà alors les gens
n'ont pas de meilleur mais là nous
dînions mélanie apprendre aux railleries
québec
je crois que c'était à eric naulleau je
voudrais pas lui griller la dent vas-y
vas-y guillaume vas-y guillaume à bono
railleries juste je voulais revenir et
se continue à dire que je comprenne pas
son agrément
ça m'embête parce que justement et je le
trouve presque assez bizarrement
contrairement à d'autres dans les propos
peu rapporte qu est-ce qui ont été vite
je trouve presque humble et pour le coup
ça ne va te dire que lui n'a pas envie
de mettre en avant cette agression parce
que beaucoup disent ce genre d'agression
et c'est bon le coup et c'est bien
peut-être la première fois que je vais
défendre avec ses mots un discours qui
ne va plutôt bien
il le trouve intelligent juste et
respectueux voilà alors juste moyennes
qui seront posées eric zemmour et les
plus sous protection policière
on s'en fout de vos achats je voulais
faire un truc le widi il a eu des propos
homophobes en octobre 2009 pardon quand
il a dit christine kelly hélas hélas on
vieillit à ça et elle replace le dal qui
achève en valais pour répondre à leurs
opinions ont été maigres
whissell leurs cadres à chaque fois
christine kelly et heureusement j'ai été
condamné pour ça je chope en douceur et
en os
oui mais guillaume là vous êtes hors
sujet mon chéri mengue eric naulleau
eric noll à bord d'abord c'est à eric
zemmour lui seul a accepté les excuses
ou pas moi je peux tous
tout juste dire que je ne les cours a
pas tout simplement parce qu'elles sont
en contradiction avec tout l'attitude de
celui que vous appelez un jeune homme
devant moi que je qualifie d' un autre
nom il s'est vanté avec beaucoup de
calme et beaucoup de l'orgue de son
effet c'est en contradiction totale avec
ses parts et de compression qui en est
fait et les années 30 ne s'explique que
parce qu'il a une enquête sofres
ensuite cette affaire est un formidable
révélateur quelqu'un maltraite quelqu'un
dans la rue et il pense qu'il peut s'en
tirer avec des vagues excuses et on
entend chez monsieur mais l'année ils
étaient les autres les formes d' excuses
de justification et de demande d'un puma
nantais pour ces gens là enfin l'accord
c'est un accord eric façon décente et
que vous avez raison de défendre les
femmes les homosexuels et les autres et
je serai toujours à vos côtés dans ces
moments là on avait utilisé les mêmes
arguments arrêter de faire du violon
oh je trouve que la victime a bien parlé
vraiment c'est bien excuser d'avoir été
victime s'cusez moi ce langage ce n'est
plus le moment de le tenir maintenant il
faut obtenir un autre langage un langage
de fermeté sinon ce sera la loi du plus
fort dans la rue qui régnera et les
personnes que vous défendez en seront
des victimes comme les autres mais
blessé les new technologies vous croyez
que c'est pas déjà le cas
vous savez vous avez bien vu excusez moi
c'est le cas de tout un chacun et ce
n'est pas pour ça que c'est plus
acceptable c'est eric zemmour je ne dis
pas ça pour arrêter une fois encore de
répéter mais leur dit c'est ma crise
terrible de dire que je n'ai pas
cautionner cela ne l'a pas dit ça il a
pas cautionner leur ai jamais cautionné
jeudi et de suivre le soleil donc il
même le seul à parler d'intimidation est
une violence n'est sûr et hop les
glissements avec ont passé au peigne
alors si au ps on perd beaucoup père
exor eric naulleau et guillaume mélanie
pour l'instant les cherry hill catski
mais ce qui a mis le feu aussi aux
poudres c'est aussi bien sûr cette
convention de la droite qui avait fait
énormément parler en septembre dernier
lors de son discours il a qualifié les
immigrés de colonisateur a même parlé
d'islamisation de la rue on
expliquant qu'il avait peur que la race
de l'homme blanc hétérosexuel soient
exterminées alors c'est plein de petites
voix la déclaration comme ça voilà il ya
plein de gens qui disent on ne cautionne
pas ce qui lui est arrivé à eric zemmour
mais mine de rien par écran interposé et
par tout ce qui fait ils nous insultent
tous les jours donc c'était une façon
voilà lui répondre mais la façon qu'a eu
ce gars ont dû répondre c'était pas du
tout la bonne la bonne la bonne réponse
parce que allait discuter avec eric
zemmour et vous dire pourquoi vous dites
ça pourquoi vous dit ceci pourquoi vous
dites cela comme vous le faites tous les
soirs
christine kelly c'était beaucoup plus
enrichissant et serait beaucoup plus
faire avancer le dialogue j'ai envie de
dire regardez cet extrait regardez cet
extrait reprendra la parole aux gens qui
en avaient fait miroiter une libération
et qui avait légitimement cru les femmes
les jeunes les homosexuels les bases
entre les juifs les protestants les
années tous ceux qui centaine inopinées
mal au sein de la majorité des mâles
blancs hétérosexuels catholique et qui
ont joyeusement déboulonner la statue
ont un rythme saccadé des déhanchements
de meech guerre dans ceux là ont été les
idiots utiles d'une guerre extermination
de l'homme blanc hétérosexuel
alors ça voilà ça a énormément parlé
christine kelly
qu'est ce que vous dites vous vous
travaillez tous les soirs avec eric
zemmour quand vous avez vu ça mine de
rien vous vous êtes dit quoi et tu es ce
que vous avez eu de la peine pour lui
est ce que vous vous êtes dit je
comprends ce jeune homme ou pas du tout
est ce qu'on vous dit
c'est son lot quotidien est ce que vous
êtes je vais l'appeler pour essayer de
voir comment il va les succès passés
je les ai contactés pour savoir comment
il allait je me suis dit que c'est son
lot quotidien cette fois ci ça a été
filmé mais en général ce n'est pas
forcément film et je me suis dit que moi
aussi je me suis fait cracher dessus
parce que je fais cette émission avec
vos mots on en a parlé de chavet oui si
ça continue encore on doit accepter ça
s'est arrêté depuis qu'on en a parlé
publiquement ça s'est arrêté mais je dis
que je me suis dit et pour ma remarque
aussi par rapport à ça c'est que il ya
une confusion des violences c'est à dire
qu'il ya un mélange on ne peut pas
répondre à eric zemmour c'est
intéressant de voir pour moi jouer
pendant ces trente sept secondes où il a
filmé eric zemmour il a expliqué que
après il a expliqué qu'il ne pouvait pas
répondre à eric zemmour d'eau qu'il ne
pouvait cacher comme ça et je vais
inviter voilà et la réalité que c'est
que
il a envie de s'exprimer il ne sait pas
comment penser sa façon de s'exprimer il
faut expliquer que c'est pas la bonne
façon de s'exprimer
nous à la reine quelle qu'elle soit et
même la haine venant d'eric zemmour il
ya quelques temps il n'a été condamné
pour ses propos à la haine
maintenant il fait très attention à ses
propos mais pour revenir aussi à la
convention de la droite la droite
quand vous avez un diffusé hier cyril
c'était pas ça n'avait pas vocation à
être diffusée c'est à dire que l'âge de
révision on peut pas dire des choses
comme ça justement on doit maîtriser
parce qu'on parle d'un plus grand dont
justement pour ne pas heurter les
sensibilités
alors si vous nous rejoignez on parle
d'eric zemmour et de l'agression dont il
a été victime on va la revoir
une troisième fois voilà pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent vous allez nous dire
voilà ce que je nomme qui s'est excusé
dernier à ce que vous accepté ses
excuses ou pas bien sûr et naulleau nous
a dit accueillir x zemmour qui peut
accepter ses excuses ou pas regardez on
la renvoie et on en parle encore avec
son vestiaire vous êtes énorme émoi
ouais sécrestat précédent et vous a fait
plaisir en tout cas ça a coupé il y
avait des gouttes de pluie qui tombait
sur mon téléphone j'ai pas pu fournir la
vidéo jusqu'au bout je peux vous dire
qu'il a goûté un mollard à l'aide
spéciale alors je j'ai une question à
poser à eric naulleau et christine kelly
votre travail écrit il n'est plus sous
protection policière l'exeo parce que on
va voir une vidéo un moment il était
sous protection policière c'est une
vidéo qui avait fait énormément parler
regardez vous allez nous dire s'il est
plus parce que c'est ce que j'ai pas
compris mon le voyant qu'une seule dans
la rue regarder
non plus
voilà alors il n'est plus sous
protection policière
christine erik dralans je ne crois pas
qu'ils soient sous une une joie qui
n'est plus sous protection policière et
eric zemmour après avoir discuté avec
lui il trompe les ira se fondre dans la
masse il dit qu'il n'a pas se cacher et
dit qu'il peut aller faire ses courses y
prend le métro il vit sa vie au
quotidien
et parce que s'ils commencent à se
cacher il ne va pas à s'en sortir donc
c'est quelqu'un comme a dit aussi son
avocat qui n'a pas peur et qui osent
affronter la vie au quotidien
parce que c'est son lot quotidien et
semble s'est pas suffisamment c'est que
tous les jours il vit ce genre de scène
eric naulleau est là il ne l'était pas
dans la scène qu'on a vu moi je préfère
pas à répondre à cette question pour des
raisons de confidentialité puisque je
peux dire j'ai la donne en effet la
dernière fois que j'ai assisté un
incident de ruben nous étions tous les
deux dans le métro donc en effet même si
tout le temps parce qu'il va dire dans
l'alizé mont houy avec moi ça m'arrive
c'est pour ça que quand je vois les gens
prendre à la légère ce genre d'incident
que j'attends que ça leur arrive et puis
on en reparlera je crois qu'on
sous-estimé l'ampleur de ce phénomène
sous-estimé la fréquence et la gravité
de ces phénomènes mais vous reviendrai
sur terre un jour non mais je trouve que
c'est que sinon je dis que c'est pas
pardon très rapidement mais je dis que
j'ai beaucoup entendu eric naulleau je
comprends ce qu'il dit et et je le pense
mais je trouve que c'est notre bien non
plus d'être un oiseau de mauvaise augure
et de dia comme bien sûr bientôt on va
on va tous crever et un jour qui m'a
arrêté dans la journée
généreux avec lui ouais ben ça y est les
eric esquisse de cana journalistes pour
me dire qu'est ce que tu vas mourir
assassiné parce que tu bosses avec
zemmour
enfin c'est parfois ya des choses qui se
disent pas je trouve que ça moi je te
dis séquence des graves
je suis d'eric et réunit les
qualifications pour grimper à venir 2002
j'en ai ri eric vous vous avez déjà été
pris à partie dans la rue très souvent
oui bien sûr je vous le dis je n'entre
pas dans les détails mais de manière
beaucoup plus violente que ce que vous
avez montré dans la vidéo avec avec
zemmour et quand vous avez été confronté
à ça quand vous êtes face à 10 personnes
qui vous insulte qui vous intimide
physiquement vous voyez la chose un peu
autrement c'est pas jouer les oies
de mauvaise augure puisque je vous parle
pas de ce qui va arriver je vous parle
de ce qui est arrivé là c'est pas bien
grave où les chenilles et un souci mais
je suis il se passera quelque chose est
sûre vous avez dit sur les réseaux vous
avez dit va voir un drame un jour
forcément censé arriver
vous savez pourquoi il y aura un drame
pourquoi j'en suis convaincu parce que
ce type
non seulement ce livre à ce méfait mais
en plus se vante sur les réseaux sociaux
ça veut dire qu'ils pensent qu'à une
chambre d'impunité et 10 minutes avant
pour lui est ce moi ça veut ça le sera
encore plus de l'agression que le titre
alors de coutras ont baissé parce qu'il
y en a et se fait le savez qui est
l'enquêteur il ya une enquête qui a été
ouverte
est ce que vous pensez qu'il va y avoir
des sanctions votre jeune homme ce qui
est une enquête qui a été ouverte aux
médias
il aura d'esprit et donc été tendre r
j'espère juste pour répondre à la
question précédente
évidemment qu'il y est il ressent une
forme d'impunité quand vous avez à
longueur de journée d aurélien tâches et
les soi-disant autoproclamé progressiste
qui à chaque fois sont dans la culture
de la victimisation et de l'exclusion a
aucune raison pour ce pays ne se sent
pas complètement immunisé contre toute
forme de poursuites y compris moral ça
c'est la première chose je suis heureux
d'entendre nodo faire sont agréés eric
naulleau faire son analyse parce que
jusqu'à présent prononcé le mot de
racailles c'était un ou des scans droite
je suis heureux de savoir que enfin il
s'est essayé par rapport à l'idée de
refuser de croire il y en avoir pour moi
un moment monsieur alassane qui n'aurait
on pas de vous lasser ça s'est
relativement bien placé en plein doutes
sont permis et rien n'a jamais rien très
bien il je termine justement ce que je
voulais dire c'est que le drame dont
vous parlez il a dit en réalité déjà eu
lieu
parce que quand on excuse ce type de
comportement et bien c'est aussi faire
l'apologie de ce qui s'est passé en 2015
avec charlie hebdo
parce que qu'est ce qu'on entendait à
l'époque de charlie hebdo c'était de
dire mais finalement charlie hebdo a
insulté le prophète il a insulté l'islam
et donc quelques à vous aviez aussi
toute une frange des intellectuels qui
disait mais finalement quelque part ils
ont un peu cherché donc le drame il a
déjà eu lieu
il a déjà c'est même des centaines de
victimes là c'est un cetain un
totalitarisme le post 6 tu peux dire
c'est que les agressions low cost mais
en réalité le drame dont vous parlez il
a déjà eu lieu à de multiples reprises y
compris les terroristes qui soigne un
jean médias on est très pressé guillaume
mélanie voulais rajouter un petit truc
et après je voudrais connexion agents
médias
juste dire que on est tous concernés ici
dans cette conversation on est tous des
personnalités publiques ou
semi-publiques on sait tous mes trajets
drummond a tout d'un super trash et dans
la rue donc quand je dis je ne cautionne
pas cette agression mais je peux
entendre aussi la colère des personnes
qu'il a insulté ça ne veut pas dire que
c'est quoi cette accusation et je sais
aussi de quoi je parle pour être
agressés chaque jour parce que je suis
homosexuel
parce que je passe chez triland là parce
que je vous prends ma gueule bon je sais
aussi de quoi je parle non à celui ci de
nous rabaisser au truc de redescendez
sur terre et vous verrez le jour où ça
va vous arriver
merci guillaume jan messia géant
messieurs
on est en période de confinement
genlissiens est-ce que n'ai pas envie
quand on sera tous d'aider confiné que
tout rentre rentrer dans l'ordre on soit
dans une danse dans un voilà dans un
monde apaisé
voilà où tout le monde accepte tout le
monde ou voilà où l'offre est ce que est
ce que vous y avez pensé à ça ce que
vous avez revu un petit peu votre
discours ou pas du tout ben justement
mon engagement politique mon cher
stérile
c'est effectivement pour apaiser la
société parce que la description de la
société n'est pas les mots que l'on met
sur une réalité si vous voulez ce sont
pas les mots qui sont haineux c'est la
réalité elle même
il est lorsque tous les jours vous avez
des attaques des agressions des
violences le non respect du confinement
actuellement et que vous dites ça on
vous emmène les gens mais il ya un
discours de m y tient un discours
réalise non j'en mets siamois moi ce que
je vous puisque je vous reproche et je
vais vous le dire
voilà encore une fois c'est que je pense
aussi que vous vous servez de ces petits
cédétiste ces phénomènes pour essayer de
tirer aussi la couverture avoué pour
dire c'est toujours les même mois les
paroles comme ça c'est toujours les
mêmes parce que ceux qui sortent suis
désolé lalalala jean bessière vous avez
parlé de gens qui ne respectent pas le
confinement c'est pas ce dont vous
parlez ceux qui respectent pas le
confinement on a vu la vidéo dans le 18e
il ya dix jours c'était pas des gens
dont vous parlez alors messieurs arrêtez
de mettre tout le monde dans le même
temps les membres seront arrêtés une
autre est toujours les mêmes genres du
doigt à répéter ils ont montré les mêmes
aujourd'hui voilà vous pouvez pas vous
ne pouvez pas m'accuser de ça pour une
raison simple c'est que je semblais bien
conscient si vous voulez que il n'ya
rien de monolithique l'immigration par
exemple les gens d'origine étrangère ne
sais pas c'est pas quelque chose de
monolithique sur lesquels on enlève des
fantasmes les les
d'origine étrangère sont comme les
français sont comme tous les pelles et
les personnes du monde via des baux il
ya des mauvais le fait de dire qu'il y a
effectivement de mauvais français de
mauvaises personnes d'origine étrangère
il faut juste qualifié les voyous
quelles que soient leurs origines et les
mettre hors d'état de nuire
- c'est vrai si vous voulez si ces
comportements là étaient minoritaires
or vous voyez bien l'explosion de la
délinquance qui les chinois mais moi je
vais vous dire moi la vidéo que j'ai vu
dans le xviiie s'était pas ni dégâts des
racailles comme vous dit tout
moi j'aime pas du tout ce mot là et
c'était inadmissible ce que j'ai vu dans
le xviiie et ça n'avait rien à voir avec
les gens dont vous parlez vous c'est moi
qui suis tjrs aime les gens qui chantent
et qui dansent est il respecté pas le
confinement c'est sûr enfin ils sont pas
accueillis les faire arrêter pour moi
pour moi c'est inadmissible ce qu'ils
ont fait je vous le dis c'est
inadmissible et si les gens même niveau
que ce que de vous parler voilà